-Good evening,
I'm Seth Meyers, everybody.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are gonna get to the news.
President Biden visited
the Pentagon on Sunday
to commemorate the anniversary
of the September 11th attack
and said, "It's not enough
to stand up
for democracy once a year."
"I don't know, I'm making it
work," said Joe Manchin.
[ Laughter ]
White House officials
are reportedly holding
emergency meetings to prevent
a potential national
railroad strike,
but just in case,
Biden's ready if you need him.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke
about his infrastructure plan
yesterday in Boston.
Said one Boston resident,
"Wow, I've never gotten a DUI
on a paved road before."
[ Laughter ]
We could have given him a shirt.
According to the latest numbers
from the Bureau of Labor
statistics, gas prices
have decreased
for 89 consecutive days,
or as Fox News reported it,
"Biden leaves oil markets
in shambles."
[ Laughter ]
Buckingham palace will
reportedly only extend
invites to Queen Elizabeth's
funeral to current
heads of state,
and no former presidents,
which is a bummer 'cause we all
kind of wanted to hear
that eulogy.
"Elizabeth, she loved
everyone at Hogwarts."
[ Laughter ]
"Even the gingers,
even the gingers."
[ Laughter ]
"And if she were here,
I -- I know what she would say.
She would say January 6th
was mostly Antifa."
[ Laughter ]
Apple yesterday released
its IOS 16 software,
which will allow iPhone users
to unsend messages,
and not a moment too soon.
[ Laughter ]
The Emmy Awards ceremony
was held last night.
Our show was nominated
and, honey,
clear some space on the mantle,
cause they had snow globes
at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "awws" ]
[ Applause ]
Elon Musk's college girlfriend
is auctioning off
personal items
from their relationship,
including photographs,
a birthday card
and upwards of three kids.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "ohs" ]
That's why we win
the snow globes, baby.
[ Laughter ]
Princeton University
announced last week
it will cover all costs
for undergraduate students
for families making
less than $100,000 a year.
Said school officials,
"It's not their fault
their parents went to Brown."
[ Audience "ohs" ]
That's the sort of cutting
ivy league humor...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to a new
survey, 26% of Americans
said that if they were
reading a book
and not enjoying it,
they would still finish it.
"Thank you," said Dan Brown.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We are off and running.